do you worry about some of the
concerns of bots being present on social
networks more and more human-like Bots
that are
not necessarily trying to do a good
thing or they might be explicitly trying
to do a bad thing like phishing scams
yeah like social engineering all that
kind of stuff which has always been a
very difficult problem for social
networks but now it's becoming almost a
more and more difficult problem
well I think there's a few different
parts of of this so one is
there are all these harms that we need
to basically fight against and prevent
and and that's been you know a lot of
our Focus over the last
you know five or seven years is
basically ramping up very sophisticated
AI systems not generative AI systems
more kind of classical AI systems to be
able to
um you know categorize and classify and
identify
okay this this post looks like it's um
promoting terrorism this one is you know
like exploiting children this one is
um looks like it might be trying to
inside violence this one's an
intellectual property violation so
there's there's like that's like 18
different categories of of violating
kind of harmful content that we've had
to build specific systems to be able to
track and
um
I think it's certainly the case that
advances in generative AI
will test those
um
but at least so far it's been the case
and and I'm optimistic that it will
continue to be the case that we will be
able to bring more computing power to
Bear to have even stronger AIS that can
help defend against those things so
um we've had to deal with some
adversarial issues before right it's I
mean for for some things like hate
speech it's like people aren't generally
getting a lot more sophisticated like
the average person who let's say you
know if someone's saying some kind of
racist thing right it's like they're not
necessarily getting more sophisticated
at being racist right it just it's okay
so that the system can just find but
then there's other adversaries who
actually are very sophisticated like
nation states doing things and you know
we find
whether it's Russia or you know just
different countries that are basically
standing up these networks of
um of bots or or
um inauthentic accounts is what we call
them because they're not necessarily
Bots that some of them could actually be
real people who are kind of masquerading
as other as other people but they're
acting in a coordinated way
and some of that behavior has gotten
very sophisticated and it's very
adversarial so they you know each
iteration every time we find something
and stop them
um they kind of evolve their behavior
they don't just pack up their bags and
go home and say Okay We're not gonna try
you know at some point they might decide
doing it on meta Services is not worth
it they'll go do it on someone else if
it's easier to do in another place but
um but
we have a fair amount of experience
dealing with
even those kind of adversarial attacks
where they just keep on getting better
and better and I do think that as long
as we can keep on putting more compute
power against it and and if we're kind
of one of the leaders in developing some
of these AI models I'm quite optimistic
that we're going to be able to keep on
um pushing against the kind of normal
categories of harm that you talk about
fraud scams spam
um IP violations things like that what
about like creating narratives and
controversy to me it's kind of amazing
how a small collection of yeah uh what
did you say inauthentic accounts so it
could be Bots but yeah I mean we have
sort of this funny name for it but we
call it coordinated inauthentic Behavior
yeah it's it's kind of incredible how a
small collection of folks can create
narratives create stories yeah
especially if they're viral so if
especially if they have a element they
can uh catalyze the virality of the
narrative yeah and I think there the
question is you have to be
I'm very specific about what is bad
about it right because I think a set of
people
coming together
or organically bouncing ideas off of
each other and a narrative comes out of
that
is not necessarily A Bad Thing by itself
if it's if it's kind of authentic and
organic that's like a lot of what
happens and how culture gets created and
how art gets created and a lot of good
stuff so that's why we've kind of
focused on this sense of coordinated and
authentic Behavior so it's like if you
have a network of you know whether it's
Bots some some people masquerading as
different accounts
um but you have kind of someone pulling
the strings behind it
um and trying to kind of act as if this
is a more organic set of behavior but
really it's not it's just like one
coordinated thing
that seems problematic to me right I
mean I don't think people should be able
to have coordinated networks and not
disclose it as such
um but that again you know we've been
able to deploy pretty sophisticated Ai
and you know counter-terrorism
groups and things like that to be able
to identify a fair number of these
coordinated and authentic networks of
accounts and and take them down
um we continue to do that I think we're
we've you know so it's one thing that if
you told me 20 years ago it's like all
right you're starting this website to
help people connect at a college and you
know in the future you're going to be
you know part of your organization is
going to be a counter-terrorism
organization with AI to find coordinated
and authentic I would have thought that
was
pretty wild but um but but it's um but
no I think that's that's part of where
we are but look I think that these
questions that you're pushing on now
um
this is actually where I guess most of
the challenge around AI will be
for the foreseeable future I think
there's a lot of debate around things
like is this going to create existential
risk to humanity and I think that those
are very hard things to disprove one way
or another my own intuition is that the
point at which we become close to super
intelligent is super intelligence is
um I I it's it's just really unclear to
me that the current technology is gonna
gonna get there without another set of
of significant advances
but that doesn't mean that there's no
danger I think the danger is basically
amplifying the kind of known set of of
harms that people or or sets of accounts
can do and we just need to make sure
that we really focus on
um
on on basically doing that as well as
possible so that that's a that's
definitely a big Focus for me well you
can basically use large language models
as an assistant
of how to cause harm on social networks
so you can ask it a question
um
you know meta has very impressive
coordinated inauthentic account
uh fighting capabilities how do I do the
coordinating authentic account
uh creation where meta doesn't detect it
like literally ask that question and
they and basically there's this kind of
part of it I mean that's what open AI
show that they're concerned with those
questions uh perhaps you can comment on
your approach to it how to do
kind of moderation on the output of
those models that it can't be used to
help you coordinate harm in all the full
definition of what the harm means yeah
and that's a lot of the fine tuning and
the the alignment training that we do
is basically you know when we when we
ship
AIS across the our products a lot of
what we're trying to
make sure is that if you can't ask it to
help you commit a crime right it's um
uh
so I think training it to kind of
understand that
and it's not that not like any of these
systems are ever going to be 100 perfect
but
you know just making it to that
this isn't a an easier way to go about
doing something bad
then the next best alternative right I
mean people still have Google where they
you know you still have search engines
so
um the information is is out there
um and
for for these
you know what we see is like for nation
states or you know these actors that are
trying to pull off these large
you know coordinated in authentic
networks to to kind of influence
different things at some point when we
just make it very difficult they do just
you know try to use other services
instead right it's it's just like if you
can make it more expensive for
um for them to do it on your service
then
then kind of people go go elsewhere and
I think that that's that's the bar right
it's like it's not like okay are you
ever going to be perfect at finding you
know every adversary who tries to attack
you it's I mean you try to get as close
to that as possible but
um but I think really kind of
economically we're just trying to do is
make it that it's it it's just
inefficient for them to to go after that
uh but there's also complicated
questions of uh what is and isn't harm
what isn't isn't misinformation so this
is one of the things that Wikipedia has
also tried to face I remember asking
um GPT about whether the virus leaked
from a lab or not and the answer
provided was a very nuanced one
and a well-sided one almost dare I say
well thought out one
uh balanced I would hate for that Nuance
to be lost through the process of
moderation
uh Wikipedia does a good job on that
particular thing too but from pressures
from governments and institutions it's
you could see some of that nuance and
depth of
uh information facts and wisdom be lost
absolutely and that's that's a scary
thing some of the magic
some of the edges the rough edges may be
lost to the process moderation of AI
systems
so how do you get that right I I really
agree with what you're pushing on I mean
the the core
I think the core shape of the problem
is that there's some harms that I think
everyone agrees are bad right so
sexual exploitation of children right
like you're not gonna get many people
who who think that that type of thing
should be allowed on any service right
and that's something that we that we
face and try to push off the you know as
as much as possible today
um you know terrorism
um inciting violence right it's like we
went through a bunch of these these
types of harms before
um
but then I do think that you get to a
set of harms where there is more social
debate around it
um so misinformation I think is
um
has been a really tricky one because
there are things that are
kind of obviously false
right that are maybe factual
um
but may not be harmful
um since the guard are you gonna censor
someone for just being wrong it's you
know if there's no kind of harm
implication of what they're doing I
think that's there's there's a bunch of
real kind of issues and challenges there
but then I think that there are other
places where it is
um you just take some of the stuff
around covet earlier on in the pandemic
where
um there were you know real Health
implications but there hadn't been time
to fully vet a bunch of the scientific
assumptions and you know unfortunately I
think a lot of the kind of establishment
done that
um you know kind of waffled on a bunch
of facts and you know asked for a bunch
of things to be censored that in
retrospect ended up being you know more
debatable or or true and that stuff is
really tough right really undermines
trust and and that and
um
so I I do think that the questions
around how to manage that are are are
very nuanced the way that I try to think
about it is that um
it goes I think it's best to generally
boil things down to
the harms that people agree on so when
you think about you know is something
misinformation or not I think often the
more Salient bit is
is this going to potentially leave lead
to um
to physical harm for someone
um and kind of think about it in that
sense and then beyond that I think
people just have different preferences
on how they want things to be flagged
for them I think a bunch of people would
be like prefer to kind of have a flag on
something that says hey a fact Checker
thinks that this might be false or
um yeah I think Twitter's Community
notes implementation is quite good on on
this
um but again it's the same type of thing
it's like just kind of discretionarily
adding a flag because it makes the user
experience better but it's not it's not
you know trying to take down the
information or not I think that you want
to reserve the kind of censorship of
content to things that are of known
categories that that people generally
agree or bad
yeah but there's so many
things especially with the pandemic but
there's other topics where there's just
deep disagreement fueled by politics
about what is and isn't harmful
there's uh even just the degree to which
the virus is harmful and the degree to
which
the vaccines the response to the virus
are harmful there's just there's a
almost like a political divider on that
and so
how do you make decisions about that
where half the country in the United
States or some large fraction of the
world has very different views from
another part of the world
is there a way
out of the uh I mean the moderation of
this I think we
it's very difficult to
just abstain but but I think we should
be clear about which of these things are
actual safety concerns
and which ones are a matter of
preference in terms of how people want
information flagged right so we did
recently introduce something that allows
people
to have fact checking not affect the
distribution of of
um of what shows them their products so
if a bunch of people don't trust who the
fact Checkers are all right well you can
you can turn that off if you want but if
the if the if the content you know
violates some policy like it's inciting
violence or something like that it's
still not going to be allowed so I I
think that you want to honor people's
preferences on on that as much as
possible
um
but look I mean this is really difficult
stuff I think the it's really hard to
know where to draw the line on
what is fact and what is opinion because
the nature of science is that nothing is
ever a hundred percent known for certain
you can disprove certain things but
you're constantly testing new hypotheses
and
um you know scrutinizing Frameworks that
have been long held and every once in a
while you for you throw out something
that was working for a very long period
of time and it's very difficult but
um but I think that just because it's
very hard and just because their edge
cases doesn't mean that you
you should not
try to give people what they're looking
for as well